[Music]
all right guys
bang bang i've got josh richards here
what's going on man thank you for doing
this
hey thank you for having me man you
you're like the king of podcasts now i
feel like you've got like a million
podcasts and uh
are on everyone's podcast no yeah i
think that i've done
about a podcast a day for the last month
that's what it feels like all right how
the hell did you get famous on the
internet what's your story
yes so it's it's kind of a weird one
but i started because my sister just
threw me in a video
uh it was back in the musically days
four years ago
uh and it was at the start of the 2016
summer and then
the video blew up on her account people
started asking her like yo what's what's
his account what's his at
and i didn't have one so i was like oh
i'll make one this would be fun right
and instantly i'm i'm like i'm an
athlete and i'm very competitive right
like that's just that's how i was
raised that's just in my blood and it's
everything i do i have to be the best at
so for the social media i instantly
turned it into like a goal
like a bunch of goals a bunch of numbers
i had to hit and it was like if i don't
hit
10 000 followers by the end of this
summer i'm quitting i'm done
it didn't work out for me so i started
working really hard instantly like hired
my sister put her on a 15
salary-based commission was like
treating it exactly like a business
um and then slowly but surely just
started building myself up
like i was focusing a lot on the live
stream uh part of musically because
no one was really touching like that
part of the app they were just focusing
on the videos and there were only like
three
top live streamers so i didn't have as
much competition if i was going there
and i was a small creator i only had
60 000 followers at this point right and
that was like a whole next year 2017.
and so i got my sister to go to every
single leaderboard that was on the
livestream app if that was the top
gifters
top likers whatever it is so i was going
right to these fans right i had like
the access of the customer right in
front of me and they were the highest
spending customers too because i
actually had the leaderboard
so this way i'm reaching the most
important people i
became one of the most like top paid um
live streamers on the app actually with
only 100 000 followers when i was going
up against these accounts with like 10
million 12 million followers
so that's where i all started it was it
was always treated like a business
how much money were you making when
you're the top uh live streamer on
musically
back then four years ago i was doing i
was probably doing like two thousand
dollars a night going live
okay and you're going live every single
night yeah
okay so you're making so you're making
what like 50 60 000
a month yeah it was it was probably
the craziest thing for like a 16 year
old
i mean it was off and on too because i
also was playing sports so i wouldn't
say was like 2k every night because
there were some nights sadly like i
would be like
i had a hockey game or i had this right
and it's like so i
wasn't able to focus on my social media
but uh
yeah that's about what it was like every
time i was going live it was just
the craziest thing okay so how do you
get from musically to the big tick-tock
audience
uh so when musically went
completely dead right like actually even
when i started when i was 14 it was on
the down
it was on the decline right uh so
it was like i the app had lasted another
year or two
and now tick tock came in and bought it
everyone was pretty much saying like
this app is over
it's done like tick-tock's going to be a
joke no one's going to use this
app and i was actually live streaming
because like i said like i was really
focused on being a live streamer
and that was part of like my brand i
would say on tick tock
musically i was streaming while they
actually transferred it the update was
coming out at 12 i was live at the exact
same time i wanted to see if like the
app crashed
if everyone's accounts restarted and
nothing happened
literally not one thing i was live
everything stayed the same so i was like
what the heck
waited 10 more minutes got off updated
the app
and it was just the exact same thing
with a different logo on it right and
then i noticed
the one difference this crazy difference
was the 4u page
and i knew that had to be special
because that's like this random change
to the
the scrolling feature like i'm seeing
all these videos with people i didn't
follow i was confused right
and i studied it for the next two weeks
all i did was watch the videos that were
coming up
see what about those videos was unique
compared to others
why those ones were doing the best and i
found out it all had to do with shares
and comments
so then i was like all right what video
is gonna blow me up
and blow up my account that is gonna
cause people to share it
save it or like comment on it so i was
like
tutorials easy who doesn't save a
tutorial right
like you want to have it for later so
when you are going to do it
it's right there in your saved videos so
i did a first tutorial video
70 million views what was that what were
you giving this tutorial on
it was a transition i used to do
transitions on the app
and i threw my hoodie and then like as
the hoodie kind of falls it like
it becomes me if you get kind of like
the video i'm giving
um and i did a tutorial on how to make
that video it was a quick 30 second
video
70 million views my account went up
probably 300
000 followers and maybe maybe more
honestly maybe like 500 000 just from
the one video
and since that day i was like all right
i [ __ ] got it like i know what to do
i got the algorithm down
i started posting a tutorial every
single
week and then i would also post the
video like the transition video or
whatever the video was before it
and then i would be like the captain
would be like tutorial coming soon so
then it would get people excited they
would engage more with that video
that video would blow up then i would
also get the blow up from the tutorial
video
at what point do you go from tutorials
to dancing and singing and kind of all
the things you guys do now
yeah i mean that was one of the craziest
parts
about my career is like how many times
have i had to pivot
like and it's something that i think
i've done
quite well like i just found the right
times to do it
and it was actually
the summer of 2019 before that
was clashing with the manager at the
time like awful relationship
and i was like i gotta i gotta get out
of this i have to leave so i left the
management and i
went on this tour that the manager had
told me not to do he was
like not letting me sign on to the tour
all that and i was like [ __ ] it leaving
the manager doing this tour i know i
need to do it
went on it that was called the lights
out toward the tour that actually blew
me
up and all my friends like actually like
half of this way the original sway house
of griffin
clinton i mean griffin jaden and anthony
and so when when you're
doing all of the tours and everything at
what point do you decide like hey we
should go move to la
um so we end the tour i'm in la and
i only knew jayden that was the only kid
that was in la that i knew
and we didn't really hang out on the
tour i went on um
we maybe saw each other in like the meet
and greet line like five times and just
like we're like quarter with each other
said what's up um but then i was like
i'll just reach out to him and be like
yo you want to hang out i'm going to
bryce hall's house
so i was heading over to bryce's i'd
known him kind of like
not well but just seen him at events we
were going to film content
jayden came over and we all just like
started hanging out that night we
partied that night
you know that sway life's out and
instantly just all bonded like we became
friends very very quickly
and then i met michael gruen at bryce's
house that's when we started the
conversation about talonx
and how people were getting treated miss
fairly or not treated well
and we just came off the tour so uh
that's kind of where we actually got
taken advantage of a lot of money stolen
um when we started realizing we could
actually also make a lot of money off
social media so
it all kind of came together perfectly
we were staying at bryce's at the time
so we're like let's just move in
together
sway house talonx now we're here
where did you get the sway name from
that's actually a
funny ass story we were i i remember we
were all texting each other in a group
chat like all the boys
and then michael um and we were putting
out a new york times press release
and it was going up in 12 hours and we
had no name not one name for the group
we were all looking up names in like the
first thing i think someone looked up
was probably like
a synonym for the word like clout or or
like
followers or something and i guess sway
is one
i had no idea but it's like a word that
has to do with like yeah
clout so no one liked the name
we all hated it we were like sway sounds
stupid like
it's like swaying like what the hell
like we're gonna get meme this is awful
but then no one came up with anything
better so we were like
[ __ ] it let's just send swag we're doing
it we're going with it
and then that's yeah and then sway
became sway way
i love it i love it uh when you think of
kind of like
your business or the business of josh uh
what goes into that like how
do you think about the products that you
have the companies uh how you make money
just walk me through kind of like
how you think of the things you do yeah
i mean
for us we already have the customer
right and and we've actually talked
about that a little bit before but
we have done it a complete different way
than most people usually they build the
product out then they go acquire the
customers
we have the customers just following us
liking our photos
listening to everything we say on a
daily basis which is crazy
so the best thing for us to do is listen
to our audience we got to listen to the
customers
and that's what we did with the energy
drink and by we i mean bryce and i
we were shotgunning red bulls in every
single youtube video just like
consistently going
um and we noticed these fans
were doing the exact same they started
shock getting energy drinks they were
sending us
uh videos challenging us to shotgun
against them and it was like building
this trend videos blowing up on the
floor you page on tick tock and we were
like whoa
whoa whoa stop it with the free promo
for red bull
this is getting ridiculous like we got
to figure something out
so that's kind of where we were like
let's create our own energy drink
stop giving the like the branding away
for free and
start selling our own stuff so yeah it
was just listening to the customer
and so when you think about the things
that you sell to them today there's
merchandise that you have
there's uh energy drink is there other
things
um i mean there's definitely other
things that are in the works and then
sometimes they're more like charity
angles for example unhide
is a company i just teamed up with and
they're
obviously against you know the use of
animal products and
they're trying every single day to just
keep improving their product to make it
like greener and better for this earth
so that's something that's awesome
and also built off of another company
called dog for dog
i got like i'm a part of dog for dog uh
they give back a bag of dog food to a
shelter every time someone buys one
right
yeah it depends if it's either gonna be
a passion project or something
that i'm trying to make maybe a ton of
money on or
i'm doing just for this sense of
business but yeah
definitely gotta have a little bit of
both what happens in the house
when people aren't there like what are
you guys doing i think people think that
you guys are like
running around with your shirts off like
getting hammered smoking weed and like
i don't know like face planting in the
pool or something like whatever but like
what are you
what are you guys doing when no one's
there i mean the thing is
is like there's usually never anyone
here but
us like it's this crazy thing that like
all of a sudden sway just decided to
change within the last like two months
three months
but everyone was just like all right i'm
gonna mentally mature by like three
years i don't know what happened i don't
know who
talked to who or like what was put in
the water at the sway house
but we all just decided to chill out and
i mean we're when we're all together
like we're just hanging out like we're
just boys right we're regular people a
lot of
times like people are trying to film
inside our house or they're trying to
like get into
get into the sway house like break into
our house which is like against the law
it's crazy that people think they can
just do that because we're social media
influencers but
it's like what do you expect to see like
we're not like up to some illuminati
type [ __ ] in our house like we're
regular people
like we might be like playing scrabble
or like ping pong you know what i mean
like watching a youtube video
you're not gonna get anything cool like
when you come like oh oh look at this
what are they doing
like we're gonna be like yo could you
leave we're just like trying to watch
family guy
like eat doritos like you know what i
mean
we just do regular things who's the best
at ping pong
uh we actually had a tournament
yesterday i saw and i saw there was
money on the line too
oh yeah um well you see actually i had a
bad shoulder that day
so i was just taking it easy i'll i'll
just say that to start it off so like
purposely got out first round um but one
of the managers
uh maxwell actually took the dub won it
and then
bryce lost to blake so blake seems to be
the number one
in the house right now even though like
i'm pretty sure i'm undefeated against
him but
all right and then what's going on in
terms of like when you guys go outside
of the house
i don't think people especially like the
business and investing community
understand enough they know you guys
have big social followings but
uh like if you go somewhere in los
angeles or elsewhere and you've got a
couple your friends with you
and let's say you guys go to a starbucks
or you walk into a restaurant like do
you guys just get
mobbed or do people kind of just like
hey they know who you are but they leave
you guys alone
um i mean it's
it's getting crazier every day right and
it's also hard to judge with like
i feel like code going on in the
quarantine but
i i remember like going out before covid
and like we would get people that come
up to us all the time and maybe they it
would end up building up to a group of
like
25 50 or whatever but if we're in like a
mall that's different right like you're
in a closed space of course people are
eat like gonna be able to mob you but if
you're just walking melrose
or if you're walking on sunset like the
difference from
five months ago to now is insane like
everywhere we go there's people that
know us now and
i think that it's because a lot of the
things we do are now bigger than just
ourselves like
it's not just about like me it's not
just about bryce it's not just about
griffin it's not about sway like
we're trying to make a difference and
and actually
have an impact on people so i think
that's starting to happen with a lot of
the press we're getting
um so yeah i think it's i i
it feels so like douchey to say like
yeah we get mobbed you know what i mean
like it's like
i don't want to say that but yeah we get
a lot of people that come up to us and
ask us for photos and it
it's awesome honestly like feels it
feels good to be loved
yeah and i think part of what's so
fascinating to me as i've gotten to know
you guys is like
the first time i saw i think it was
either griffin or bryce i can't remember
somebody tweeted
and uh all of a sudden i saw people
being like you know
basically like notice me like like my
tweet reply to my tweet i mean like
just crazy i was like what planet are
these guys living on
like literally that's what people want
and uh and then bryce was explaining to
me like literally just liking somebody's
tweet they go
nuts they'll screenshot they'll send it
to all their friends they'll like do all
this kind of stuff
and so like how do you think about you
know something that's like a low
friction like pretty low investment on
your
standpoint just like if you like a tweet
or you follow somebody back or you
respond or whatever
but you can't sit there and do that all
day long but when you do do it it means
something to somebody it's like how do
you think about
engaging with fans online um and how
does that do you think translate to like
the fandom that you see
in real life when they run up to you and
all that 100 i mean
that's actually why i went live like
that's why i started my career by going
live
it was because i was able to be a lot
more one-on-one with my
my supporters and my fans because i'm
constantly getting questions i'm
constantly being able to answer them
i actually was able to memorize some
people's usernames
like if they came on the live a lot like
actually build like friendships with
these
these fans and that is probably like one
of the most important things to do
if you want a dedicated fan base or like
a cult
type following right where they will
just follow you wherever you go
they're gonna like take your word on
everything and
i mean engaging is a huge part of that
if that's like sometimes i just go
through my twitter and i just go through
my mentions and i just like go through
and like when people are talking
on my name and like they're saying good
things about me i'm just liking tweets
and like fans appreciate that or
if i go through my tagged photos on
instagram and i
posted something about people going and
rating the podcast five stars right
i'll go through and just make sure to
engage with everyone because they went
and did that for me and it's like you
know what i want them to feel
something a little extra special like
it's just little things like that i
think that's important for creators to
do
especially when like dude it takes five
minutes you could probably go through in
like
150 people's posts and then they're like
they've made their week you know what i
mean absolutely and
so when you think of like if somebody's
starting out today and trying to build
these large audiences
is tick tock the place to do it is it
triller is it
twitter instagram is it something i
don't know about like where do you think
people
today if they're starting should look at
yeah i mean for me when i first started
um i was i just used musically because
it was the one
video platform like that's why i used it
it was the one place where videos were
able to go viral very easily
the thing is is now every platform has
that right
every platform has like hopped on the
tick tock wave where like these
videos are an explore page and so
it's like you can really start anywhere
i mean it's going to be probably a lot
harder to get traction on youtube off
the bat
it's going to be a little bit harder for
instagram as well but
the thing is also is like when you build
on those platforms that are a little
harder like youtube or instagram and you
build from
nothing else not tick tock not trailer
not
you build a really really engaged
platform or
followers on that platform right because
there's something about those apps like
tick tock and trailer when it's such
quick
content a lot of times people just like
and follow you for your one video that
you posted or for your content they
don't follow and like you for you
and that's the difference between
youtube is it's a long form con it's
long-form content
they see really who you are they see
what you like what you care about
and then they get attached to that
instead is it fair to say that you guys
put way more time and energy into the
youtube videos and the tick tocks are
more of like
hey there's a dance that's going viral
or you just pull the song
and listen you know and kind of sing
along to it or whatever yeah i mean i
think that also
like people say like tik tok so easy
right and like i'll give it to them like
you know what i mean like
putting a video in front of yourself or
a camera in front of yourself filming
like 15 second videos it's it's not that
hard
but the thing is is knowing the
difference like being able to just look
at a video and know
instantly the difference between like is
this video gonna go viral or is it not
like
it's not impossible anyone can do it it
takes practice and like it takes a few
years but like
that's a real thing right like there's
there's a real part of it where it's
like
the creators like people i think the sue
house has it really well well they
they've just developed like a viral eye
right where they can just see a video
and they'll be like i know that's going
to go
big on tick tock so it doesn't take us
as long anymore
and we're able to focus on other
platforms where we're not so
um you know like savvy like youtube
we we're getting better but we have only
been doing youtube for eight nine months
where tick tock's been
four years yeah and and i also think
it's just you build muscle memory right
it's like you have practice yeah
you know yeah you know what works and
what doesn't uh do you guys work
together at all from a content
distribution standpoint like will you
ever post a video and then send it to
the other guys and they all engage with
it to kind of
drive it on whatever platform or is it
kind of just now you guys have such big
audiences you don't need to do that
stuff anymore
each other's [ __ ] like you've got to do
that right that's just a part of being
like the boys like
there's never one time i don't see like
jaden for example
he posted a a song promo today he's
coming out with a new song soon
um better off dead shout out to jaden um
but
he i instantly just reposted that on my
story like it wasn't like jaden told me
to
or i felt like i needed to it's just
kind of our attitude towards each other
like
i would feel less successful if jaden
wasn't successful and i
i hope and i i know like the boys have
that same mentality towards me or
towards any of the boys you know
yeah uh what's up with all the drama in
terms of like
you guys are 20 21 years old i feel like
you are going through everything that 20
21 year olds go through in terms of
girls and you know who's talking to who
and all this kind of nonsense
the only difference is that you're
literally doing it with like the whole
world watching basically
yeah and you know and then you got dave
asking you on a podcast like hey are you
guys dating and all of that
yeah what's that like um
i mean it's it's kind of crazy because
it it definitely does make you like
always think about what you're gonna say
right like
two three years ago i was very more just
outspoken
and i wouldn't have really watched what
i said and i got in trouble for it a lot
i mean like in school i would get in
trouble
wherever i'd get in trouble because i
just like said what was on my mind i was
just like [ __ ] it
but the thing is is like you can't
really do that
in this industry like i i can get as
close
to like the line as possible or i can
like
even go over the line which i do and
some people just look at it as like josh
is an
idiot he's tr he's like he's you know he
just is intense he's edgy whatever
it's like sometimes i want to push the
line because
i want to see how far i can go like
people
people have become so soft now it's just
like what
i don't i don't even i just can't say
anything i feel like i can't say
anything i feel like
you know it's like really hard to just
be yourself nowadays too because like
no one lets you learn from your mistakes
no one's letting you build
like and if you look back at me six
months ago i was a i was a [ __ ]
like person compared to who i am now not
because like
it's because i was younger i was 17 and
i didn't really know what i was doing
like it's just kind of like that like
people grow and
in this industry they don't let them
absolutely last question about content
is you got the podcast uh bff with uh
with portnoy
uh what's your favorite thing about dave
and what's your least favorite thing
about dave
okay um i think my favorite thing about
dave
is that he doesn't let
there be a line you know facts like
facts
he does not let there be a line he
doesn't care what people are gonna say
about him
and it sometimes it gets him in a lot of
trouble
but at the same time it's like i respect
him for it
it's no one's really doing it anymore
and people used to be able to do that
all the time that's how it was
everywhere right
so i just i just think that's absolutely
baller um
and then and by the way you're not
really doing anything if you're not
pushing the line right if you're not
trying to figure out where the lines are
right so yeah
no yeah like i would prefer to be
polarizing than just be like on
everyone's good side
you know what i'm saying like because
like if everyone's just like okay with
me or they're like yeah that guy's cool
like i'm not sticking out in anyone's
heads if i'm polarizing then there's
gonna be people that [ __ ] love me
and then there's gonna be people that
[ __ ] hate me but i'm in both of their
mouths all day long so
keep bringing me like the paycheck right
i hear you
uh but for the the thing i like that
or what i like least about dave um
gosh i feel like this about to be a
bff's uh like segment next week he's
gonna be like so josh
um but anyways um well that well now i'm
gonna send it to him so whatever you
said he's definitely gonna listen
yeah perfect um i
i would just say like i don't even know
if i have one like
it's it's like a hard situation like i
would say like it
it doesn't really bug me because i love
it for the show but him like calling me
out on
the nest stuff or like the he really
just doesn't let me like
sometimes slide you know what i mean he
never lets me slide like do you want him
to let you slide
that's the thing it's like it's a love
hate thing you know it's like sometimes
i'm like [ __ ] you man
like you really just did that like i'm
trying to like bounce
off that question obviously but then at
the same time i'm like
ah i know that's about to get a million
likes on tick tock so
why don't you ever ask him about his
love life um
i mean i think i'm just like waiting for
the right moment to attack
and just unleash like all this stuff
about dave you know what i mean like i'm
just
picking it up i'm getting an inventory
stocking up and then it's just gonna be
like
merry [ __ ] christmas do you have
inventory on them
i mean i have a few things i i mean like
some of it's like public and he just
like
that's the other thing is he just
doesn't care like it's so hard to get a
guy that just is like
yeah no that happened you're like okay
and uh like you don't know what to say
just he gets you every time
it's possible all right let's talk about
the business and investing stuff uh
why are you interested in building these
companies and investing in them
yeah i mean like like i said actually
even going back to the content stuff
like ever since i started i treated it
as a business
um i always
knew i was gonna do something like as a
kid i was gonna do something more than
just like the regular path of like going
to college and going to school like
i was seven years old being like i'm not
gonna go to college right like i already
knew that and it wasn't because i wasn't
smart
or it wasn't because i didn't like
school i strive to be the best at school
like
because like i said i'm competitive
about everything if there was one kid
that got a higher mark than me on a test
i'd get pissed
i was like [ __ ] that guy like i i know i
could have gotten
done better if i put like five more
minutes of studying right like that was
just me i was competitive everywhere so
i mean like i i did i did the hockey
business when i was like
13. i started a hockey shirt company and
then i did another one
when i was like 14 just before the the
musically thing started with lacrosse
like it was
always just building and starting new
projects and i just loved that and then
when i finally had
the like this tool social media this
lightning in a bottle
where i could actually start building
things to a
huge degree compared to selling t-shirts
door-to-door
and selling them at hockey tournaments
like i was i had to jump on the
opportunity
like i was so excited and the first one
was
talonx like i saw that there was an
issue
i saw that people weren't getting
treated fairly in the industry i saw
that
there were no managers really for social
like tick tock specifically
and i was like there's a whole as an
entrepreneur like i need to fill that
hole like that's what that's what
entrepreneurs do like and that's just
how my brain works it's like how can i
fix that problem how can i fix this
problem
so when we started doing annie
and then like going down the road with
partnering with different companies
acquiring equity
the next big thing was like all right
let's
let's start doing some investing like
why don't i put my money that i'm making
into good use as well
um so that was like a journey we started
probably
three and a half months ago i would say
or three months ago
um michael and i at least and
it was just the the coolest thing to me
at the start because
it was like i was investing in
my earlier self if that makes sense like
it gave me that feeling where i was like
i could have i would have been one of
those people if i didn't have social
media like i would be one of those
founders
going to people asking for their money
if i didn't have social media and the
money to build my companies on my own
so to like get to listen to all these
founders like and how passionate they
are but they're projects getting to
be a part of the future and be like me
knowing like
i could be investing in the next uber or
the next airbnb
the next big tech company like that is
the coolest feeling in the world to know
that i'm going to be a part of the
future
how much money did you make last year um
i did just ballpark you know tell us
exactly yeah yeah yeah i mean
i did pretty good though i'll just say
what like the forbes thing said like
they said
i did 1.5 if that so that gives you
enough
ballpark accurate yeah yeah okay all
right
so does that is your thought process
like that's gonna grow
to three four five million dollars over
the next two or three years
or do you think that kind of from an
income standpoint you'll stay
let's call it around a million and a
half and then you can invest and that's
how you're gonna grow your wealth
um i think that it will actually
probably
grow quite a bit this next year 2021 for
sure
i think like my actual uh income like
getting cash revenue will
definitely higher probably like three or
four x actually
um why do you think uh i think that
because
i just know the different like series
and
um content ideas i'm gonna be rolling
out next year there's like a lot of
exciting stuff that i'm just working on
behind the scenes that hasn't been
announced
um and we'll be working on for a while
but
it's definitely gonna be a crazy year
next year
if that stuff get hits those deadlines
got it and when you think about the
investing stuff is this just kind of
like the long-term way so like you keep
optimizing for
driving as much income as you can today
but then you're going to invest capital
and
uh that capital will grow you know kind
of illiquidly
for quite a long time and then that's
kind of the the big home run
um or do you look at it as hey i'm going
to need those investments because
this income is going to dry up at some
point and i might i want to keep doing
the content or whatever
i mean i think it's it's a little bit
of the like last one you said where it's
like kind of hedging your bets right
i mean you've got to be smart smart with
your money period like if i had
less money than i do then there would be
different plays that i'd be making right
and if i had more then there'd be
different plays i'd be making in that
sense like
it's just like knowing what you got and
being the smartest you can with it
but at the same time it's like i know
i'm making money right now
i know that i have um this like
like lightning in a bottle like i said
but i don't know if i'm gonna have it in
10 years
but what i can do for the next two maybe
three
is get connected to every young founder
get connected with every billionaire get
connected to every company
and get in with those companies be a
part of them
and then like i'm sitting here being the
future of the 10 years you know what i
mean like i am the future in 10 years
because i put my money into everything
or not everything but the right
companies so
i'm that's that's why all right when we
talk about like doing the right things
with your money
i think i feel like i i've gotten to
know you bryce griffin enough where like
you guys actually are very smart about
what you do with your money
um and you're obviously investing a lot
you guys aren't doing kind of
too crazy of things but what's the
dumbest thing you've ever done with your
money
um i think for me
it was probably buying that polaris
that polaris was probably the dumbest
purchase i ever made because
one it only busted my hand open
which was just like inconvenient and i
think i've
only drove it twice and it's only driven
it twice
yeah and it cost me like 12 grand
okay this is gonna sound this is gonna
sound crazy to people but like that's
not that bad
like it's not like you went and bought a
250 000 ferrari and then crashed it a
day later right no
or like and i'm also not the guy to like
buy 60 000
watch right or like i like even like a
watch period
it's just like i'm not that guy like i'm
the worst person to talk to when it
comes to like bad expenses because
even that expense got paid off because
it was
a tax write-off for content by the
polaris like
it's like i don't really do those dumb
purchases
anymore i would say when i started
feeling like i was making money and i
had like 100k
in the bank um it was right after like
lights out tour probably um and i was
like i hadn't got my tour money yet but
i'd been
making like a good amount of live stream
money and
i was like spending money on designer
clothes i was i probably spent
20 000 during that summer just on
clothing and it was like
why i don't wear any of it anymore
that's the best part like i don't like
that
fashion like that's just not me i'm like
a hoodie and jeans or like
a hockey jersey and pants like it's like
i don't
wear like that type of style and it's
also just like it's so flashy and
dude it just sits in my closet i hate
that i spent the money on it like i
spent
two thousand dollars on a sweater and i
haven't worn it in six months
[Music]
what did your parents say the first time
that you were like like they like
realized like oh [ __ ] our kid's like
making
like a good decent amount of money yeah
it was
um ninth grade
was like coming to an end and i was
starting to like
they started to see in their paypal like
these like 500 600
payments coming in all the time and they
were like what the heck is going on and
i kept like
being like that's my money guys don't
worry about it like that's all i would
say i just like that's mine don't worry
about it
so they probably thought i was out here
like selling drugs like they straight
thought i was just like chopping
out of our basement um but they they
came to me and they were like so josh
like
we heard like my dad heard about it at
school that i was doing like social
media that's how he like and like
i guess he had seen me like making
videos so he just like put it together
he was like like what is it what is
musically like what are you doing like
how are you making this money
and i was like you know like i go live i
stream and they give me like money and
he's like is this like
porn like so confused right my dad has
no idea like he's hearing like a live
stream donate
it's weird right like so anyway
um i ended up like kind of like showing
them the app and everything like that
but then they were instantly just like
all right that's cool like heck yeah
because they were already
used to my like crazy business schemes
and like ideas right like
i destroyed their basement already with
the lacrosse company because i was dying
the mesh and the whole carpet in our
basement was just like a tie-dyed
t-shirt
and then um i had like tried to take the
tub
where i was like bending wood to create
skin boards like so that you could go on
the beach and ride like i i always
wrecked our stuff and like so when they
finally saw that i was making money they
were probably like heck yeah now josh
can pay for this like let's
let's go and he's not gonna screw up our
house even better
yeah exactly all he has to do is go on
his phone so we're safe
all right what's your goal in terms of
10 or 20 years from now
what do you hope to kind of be able to
say like here's what i've accomplished
um i want to i definitely want
within the next 10 to 20 years for one
of my companies to have a big exit
that's like just a goal of mine right to
be able to sell one of my companies and
kind of just be able to say like
i did that i i built a company and like
that's that's just the coolest feeling i
feel like um
i would say keep investing like i want
to
have fun i want to be a part of i am a
part of the remus
fund which has been is going to be a
really cool experience but i want to
start my own as well not just come in
uh like i did there and then just like
continue with entertaining because i
love to entertain like
i do love business more than anything
but at the same time it's like i've
always been that outgoing loud kid that
was either the class clown or disrupting
assemblies or like i i did that right
like that's what i like to do so
i would love to be known still in like
this entertainment world in 10 to 20
years if that's just in a different way
that would be cool you know what i mean
all right and throughout this whole
thing last
question for you uh actually i got a
couple other questions but
uh who's the craziest like coolest
person you've met through all of this
um i've met some like super insane
people
super crazy people but like some of the
coolest people
that i met like just like right off the
bat when i started talking to them were
probably
uh sean rad was really cool when i met
him like
he just has always like been giving me
advice has always
uh just been a great mentor to me um
and then also ashton kutcher
i've got to talk to him a couple times
and he's just like
great greatest guy he's funny he's like
he's just kind of like one of the boys
i had great conversation with him and
then shaq shaq was super cool to talk to
he's just he's just
he is a funny [ __ ] dude i answer
the phone with him and every time i
answer the phone
i just know i'm about to laugh every
single time so
what's he what's he call you about i
mean sometimes it's just like
nothing sometime like one time we
chatted and he was just like saying like
yo you can call me anytime like
i'm here you if you ever need some
advice never
ever need me to ask or ask me anything
so
i was just like oh yeah so it's just
like yeah
so it's you ever take him up on it and
call oh yeah i call i was on a call with
him the other day
we were just talking about like a couple
like business ideas i was thinking about
and getting his advice on it i mean just
like those type of relationships
in the business world is so cool to have
like
having those people that are kind of
like your mentors or just like
are nice enough to help you out when you
need it that's where i've met some of
the coolest people
yeah i'll uh won't hold my breath for a
shaq and josh
tick-tock dance oh yeah oh yeah that
needs to come
maybe maybe i uh i do like a shack
versus with him i don't know if you guys
in a series where he was like going up
against pro athletes he comes up against
a pro tick tocker
all right ask the same two questions to
everybody uh first is what's the most
important book you've ever read
most important book i've ever read
um
all right this is gonna sound super dumb
but there's a there's a reason for it
right
i was a kid that hated to read when i
was younger at the start i didn't want
to read any single books so
i don't know if this is the most
important book i read but it's a book
i'm most grateful for because it did
start my like
my my love for reading because i i love
to read but
it's it's the diver wimpy kid
it's a funny answer i know probably
never got one like that on this podcast
for sure because i bet you
every [ __ ] is coming in here
with like the smartest book that they've
ever heard of right and trying to act
all like
amazing but it's diver would be kid
because i didn't like reading and that
introduced me to reading in a way where
i was like it was funny and as a like a
little kid right like it doesn't feel
like i'm reading comic book almost
and then after that i instantly went to
like percy jackson and then after that i
started reading all the harry
potters and like that was like when i
was probably in like third fourth grade
so
then i just started reading and reading
and reading and now i've read like so
many books
since i've been on la i don't think i've
actually picked up one um so i probably
got to
but uh yeah i love dennis great answer
all right second one's more fun
uh aliens are you a believer or
non-believer a 100 a believer
yeah why because it's it's like there
there's just no way there can't be like
there has got to be it's so big the
universe is so big and it's just like
we're such a small part of it i yeah
there's got to be aliens 100 percent
yeah i'm with you all right you could
ask me one question to finish up what
question you got for me ooh
all right what am i going to ask
let's see um
if okay this is a question i'm going to
ask because i actually just want to know
about it
someone that has never like bought in
crypto before because i have
not at all like
is there any other coins out there
besides like bitcoin that i should be
interested in or start looking in well
here's the way i think about it is
if you don't own any at all then you
should start with bitcoin
right and you don't need to buy a whole
bitcoin you can just buy a part of a
bitcoin
yeah like i could just put 400 bucks
into it even like a dollar
yeah whatever yeah so so it's like you
start there and then
in my opinion that's the thing that is
going to take up
majority of uh people's attention it's
going to take up majority of uh kind of
the future
returns that's the thing that is like
the most important
there's a whole bunch of other people
you're going to talk to that will
disagree with that they'll say there's
all this other stuff right
there's other things that will accrue
value but but it's just like what do you
want to focus on right what's your
advantage
and kind of lean into that advantage so
i think that for you it's like look
if you own nothing just start with
bitcoin right and then like you can go
figure out whatever you want to do but
like
bitcoin is kind of step one um and uh
and i think you want to be able to just
get started right like that's the hard
part
because it's what you're what 18 years
old yeah 18.
yeah so like my brothers i got four
younger brothers right and like each one
of them they went a long time they
didn't have any then they bought a
little bit and they buy a little bit
more and like and then just slowly like
you learn more about it whatever and
like you kind of just build up
your confidence level um you know
because you're putting money in right so
it's like hey
i don't want to go buy 20 000 bitcoin
and then be like oh [ __ ] this is stupid
so you start small and then you just
build it up
makes sense thank you all right like i
told griffin uh
i would normally ask people where we
could send them to find them on the
internet but you are
everywhere uh where do you want people
to connect with you from like the
business and uh an investing world if
they want to reach out
um i mean i i have a linkedin now so
josh richards on linkedin i did like
dude i didn't even know that was still a
thing until recently
and then i was like i was told i was
like dude who told you who told you to
get a linkedin
michael you needed linkedin josh
everyone like and i was like all right
all right i'll get well i'll get a
linkedin
and so i did so yeah everyone go check
out the linkedin if if you guys want to
connect that'll be awesome
michael's looking out for you guys man i
know for real without michael i would
not have a linkedin so that's
all right sounds good we'll talk soon
yep peace man